SPEAKER 1: Sean, hi.
GDG is a very interesting
development community.
SPEAKER 2: I'm glad somebody
has asked this question.
SPEAKER 3: This is where
the magic happens.
SPEAKER 4: This is primarily
a question and answer show.
So if any of you would like
to ask questions.
CLAUDIO: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio
and this is Vic.
We are two engineers in the
Google Drive SDK team.
Today we're going to review on
an app that is on the Chrome
Web Store and that integrates
with Google Drive.
We decided for today we wanted
to show something that might
be useful for students
going back to school.
So what is this app, Vic?
VIC: So the app is called the
Desmos Graphing Calculator.
And it's a very popular app
in the Chrome Web Store.
I have their homepage
open here.
And we can just take a look
through the core application.
So essentially what it allows
you to do is write a series of
equations that come up with a
graphical representation.
So if we scroll down here,
here's some recent graphs that
people have made.
Here's Batman.
So somebody wrote some
equations that
created a bat symbol.
CLAUDIO: How does that
help with school?
VIC: Well learning must
be fun, right?
CLAUDIO: OK.
VIC: So if you create Batman,
you'll probably learn a lot
about these equations
because these
are not trivial equations.
There's some other ones
here that are a
little bit more relevant.
So here's a couple of waves
and linear equations.
So essentially this application
is targeted at
anybody who needs to make graphs
very often, which, I
think, is largely students
working on classes.
So this is an app that
integrates with Google Drive
by the Chrome Web Store.
So to take a look today at this
app and then review it,
we're going to install it from
the Chrome web store.
So here I am in Drive, and I'm
going to get more apps.
And then when the Chrome Web
Store comes up, we're going to
see all of the Google
Drive apps.
CLAUDIO:So when you click on Get
More Apps, you're brought
to a specific collection inside
the Chrome Web Store
where you can see all the
applications that integrate
with Drive?
VIC: Yeah, so there's a lot.
But the one that we're looking
for today is Desmos Graphing
Calculator, which
is right here.
So if you click Add to Chrome,
this is going to install it.
Here we see that it came up in
the Chrome New Tab page.
I'm going to come back to Drive,
and we'll be able to
create more Graphing Calculator
by Desmos.
So if I create this, the first
thing that we have to do is
authorize the application, and
tell it that it can create
graph files on our behalf,
and store them in Drive.
So we're going to
allow access.
And then, finally, we're
taken into Desmos.
So here the graph is
currently empty
because we have no equations.
But if I enter some equations
here, like here's one for a
circle, it graphs instantly.
And we can add more equations,
like x plus y equals 2 just
for a line.
So we could continue doing
this, and then save it to
Desmos or to Drive.
So here if we click Save, it's
asking us to create a new
account or to log in.
VIC: This is a new account
on Desmos, right?
This is not a Google account.
VIC: Yeah.
The one difference is
that we can sign in
with OpenID on Google.
And then you'll notice it asks
us to authorize again.
And we come back, and now we're
actually saving the graph.
So we'll say line and circle.
And we'll just share it with
the world for now and click
Save Graph.
So here we get a permalink and
some ways to share it.
Take me back to my graph.
So one of the advantages of this
application is that you
can instantaneously graph pretty
much any equation.
It's very, very powerful
for students.
CLAUDIO: And you can also start
from someone else's
graph, and see how that
translates into equations.
Maybe it's very hard to
understand, at least for me.
But for some people, this can
be very, very easy to
understand.
And you can easily move back and
forth equation to graph.
Can you also edit it?
VIC: Yeah.
So here I could create a new
expression on this graph.
And then x squared
plus y squared--
CLAUDIO: So you can start from
someone else's equation and
extend it or change it?
VIC: Yeah.
So if we do that, then
it really is good for
collaboration between students
and teachers.
So here, maybe a teacher creates
a template graph and
then asks students to add some
equations that will intersect
certain points, or something
like that.
So super powerful app.
There's also a keypad, and
there's some other additional
settings that you can do to
customize the graphs.
Like you can change the labels
on each of the axes
and things like that.
So we're very pleased with
the core application.
What we were going to talk
about today is how they
integrate with Drive and what
they could do better or what
they already do well.
CLAUDIO: OK.
I think we can start from the
authorization mechanism.
VIC: Yeah.
So when a user originates in
Drive, they create more
Graphing Calculator by Desmos.
One of the problems is that
Desmos currently is not
automatically logging the
user in when they
originate from Drive.
And this is a problem because it
causes the user to have to
log in twice.
So here, actually, if I log out,
we can demonstrate this a
little bit more easily.
So if I create another graph.
The user should arrive at the
application logged in.
But you can see that we're
not logged in.
So this is one convenience
mechanism for users
originating from Drive.
Also, if the user originates
from Drive, there's no way to
actually save back to
Drive at the moment.
So I believe that this is
something that Desmos used to
support but removed temporarily
because of some
integration issues between
Desmos and Google Drive.
I think that those are issues
we've since resolved.
And so we're really looking
forward to Desmos bringing
this functionality back.
CLAUDIO: So what should be the
best flow for the user?
VIC: Ideally the best flow for
the user is creating a graph
from within Google Drive.
And when they land here,
they are logged in.
And they create some
graph like this.
And when they click Save,
instead of requiring the user
to log in again, or create a
Desmos account, instead of
walking through this flow, where
I have to authorize a
second time, and then do this
to save my graph, everything
is saved into Drive
automatically.
CLAUDIO: But right
now it's not.
VIC: Right.
Right now, nothing has been
saved into Drive.
In fact, if we look at all
of the files on this test
account, we can see that there's
just nothing here.
So Desmos is saving the graph
locally within Desmos.
So their Drive integration is
missing some key components
right now, primarily the ability
to create and store
graphs within Drive.
They are also missing the
component to open certain
graphing files from within
Drive, which is fine.
But if they were storing native
Desmos graphs in Drive,
then those should be open.
CLAUDIO: But they can
also store some
shortcuts to documents.
Store them there on
their server.
So it depends on their
implementation.
But one thing you can do as a
developer is that you can
still store all the data in your
back end, whatever that
is, a database, a local file
system, it doesn't matter.
But you can have shortcuts,
links, or pointers to those
documents from Google Drive.
And this is not happening
at the moment.
VIC: That's exactly right.
So it doesn't matter really
if they store this
data in Drive or not.
They could store it on
Desmos.com but link to it with
a shortcut file from
within Drive.
We need to make it clear,
though, that Desmos is a
perfect use case for integrating
like this with
Google Drive.
Here they have a single document
interface that's
working on a single
file at a time.
And if that file was stored in
Drive or a shortcut was stored
in Drive, then it would add the
ability for more users to
interact with these things
more quickly,
which is pretty important.
Also, integrating with Drive
gets you things like sharing
for free, it gets you searching
for free, and things
like this, and it allows users
to collaborate on these
documents a little
bit more quickly.
CLAUDIO: Yeah, there's also
something else they can do to
make the user experience better,
integrating better
with Google Drive.
I see there's a button that
says My Graphs on
the top left corner.
What does that do?
VIC: It shows all of your
graphs saved in Desmos.
CLAUDIO: They can probably
integrate this with Google
Drive, and show all the files
you have, all the matching
files you have, on
Google Drive.
And if developers want
to integrate with--
when I have a dialog
to pick files from
Drive, we provide that.
It's called Google Picker API.
It's part of the Google
Drive SDK.
It's a JavaScript
API you can use.
You can easily integrate it into
your application, and use
it to show the lists of files
from the user's account that
match some specific criteria.
VIC: Exactly.
So if we go to the Drive
SDK documentation at
developers.Google.com/drive
somewhere here, I think it's--
CLAUDIO: Manage Drive Files.
VIC:Yep.
And then actually, no.
I don't think it's there.
CLAUDIO: Integrate with Drive.
VIC: Yeah.
Sorry, we'll just rework
this a little bit.
So if we open files--
CLAUDIO: So there are
different ways
you can open files.
The first one we saw is that you
click on a file on Drive
UI or you create a new one,
and that saves it.
But, as a side, you could
also use a Picker.
VIC: Yeah.
So here's the documentation
about how to use the Google
Drive Picker.
And, essentially, how to embed
something contextually into
the page of your application
that will show essentially the
Google Drive dialog box that
allows you to choose files
from within Google Drive.
So you can see it's actually
pretty quick
and simple to implement.
In Desmos' case, they may have
a strong opinion that they
want users only choosing files
from within Desmos.
And that's fine.
A Drive SDK integration
is not all or nothing.
This is just another suggestion
that would make
their app easier to use from
a Drive user's perspective.
CLAUDIO: And just about
something while we mentioned
the Picker The Picker can be
used to select files from
Drive, but it can also be used
to upload files from Drive.
So let's say if you have a
client-side application or you
want the users to upload files,
you can just use the
same Picker that you use for
downloading to upload.
Maybe this is not the
case for Desmos.
I don't think they have to
upload files to Drive.
But it might be good to know.
VIC: Exactly.
Yeah.
So can you think of any other
ways that Desmos could
integrate with Drive?
CLAUDIO: I think the most
confusing part is just the
authentication and the login,
the user creation, which is
not clear for users.
What a Desmos account is, and
what a Google account is.
I mean, you think you're logged
in into Google, and you
are, and you're not logged
into Desmos.
Or you can be logged into
Desmos, but not
logged in into Google.
And this has to be as defined
as possible to the users so
that they log in once
and that's it.
And that's why we want
developers to use OpenID,
which is the technology that
allows you to delegate
authentication to Google.
VIC: So other apps get around
this in that if, for instance,
another application needed to
make a native account, they
would automatically create the
native account and associate
the incoming Google user
with that account.
So when the user arrives from
Drive, Drive also sends a
token along.
And the application should be
using this token to gain
access to a user's Drive
files when they arrive.
Because the user, after
they've installed the
application and run it from
within Drive, has already
authorized the app to access
certain files.
So that could be a little bit
cleaned up so that when I come
here and I create more Graphing
Calculator, I land
here, I'm signed in, and when
I save the file, it
automatically goes back to Drive
because that's where I
originated from anyway.
CLAUDIO: And another suggestion
I might have, it
depends on what is the file
format they use to store their
data on Drive.
So regardless if they have
only a shortcut to their
document somewhere else, or if
they store everything on
Drive, this can probably be
easily translated into some
XML file, or something like
that, some kind of text files.
Something they can do to make it
easier for Google to index
the text content so that it
can be easier for users to
find a document.
So whenever you create an
equation, but when you save
it, I think you could also add
some description fields, some
tags, or something like that.
So if that is a text file, then
Google will automatically
index that text so that users
can find it by searching for
some terms.
But if there is a binary format,
we don't have a way to
find out what the text is.
VIC: Currently within
Desmos, yeah.
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
And developers can provide some
indexable tags for us.
So there is this field in the
API that they can use so that
even if we don't know what the
file format is, and we don't
know how to open a specific
file, or read what the text
content is, you can still
provide us with some text
content, and we will index it
and we will treat it exactly
the same way as we treat
the text we index.
VIC:Yeah, exactly.
So when creating or updating a
file, applications can set the
indexable text, which is here.
So, like Claudio said, it's just
a field of keywords, a
normal text field.
And you set whatever keywords
you'd like Google to index on.
And then when the user searches
for something in
Google Drive, if one of those
keywords matches,
then we show the file.
CLAUDIO: One of the things to
mention about the indexable
text field is that field
is write only.
And you have to provide a new
indexable text field every
time you update the document
because, of course, if you
changed the content of your
document, you have to change
the indexable text
accordingly.
And if you don't provide a new
indexable text when you update
an existing file, we will assume
you just want to clear
that field, so we will store
an empty indexable text.
VIC: So this is a future request
that we've gotten is
to make the indexable text
readable by applications, and
it's something we're
considering.
So getting back to Desmos,
this is a really, really
powerful application that we
highly recommend you use.
Go to the Chrome Web Store,
install Desmos Graphing
Calculator.
It's very powerful.
I actually use it somewhat
often now that
I've discovered it.
It's very, very convenient for
just drawing graphs of
equations, which we do often.
CLAUDIO: Just to, before we wrap
up, so you showed how to
get to the Chrome Web Store
when you start from Drive.
And that is really easy.
So you said you wanted
to create something.
You don't have an application,
so you do more, and
you get more apps.
And this will land you
directly to the Drive
application collection.
What if you start from the
Web Store directly?
How do you find this collection
inside Drive?
VIC: That's a good point.
CLAUDIO: The Web Store.
VIC: So if we just land in the
normal Chrome Web Store, this
is what it looks like.
You can see various types
of applications here.
If you want to see all of the
Google Drive applications,
just go to Collections and
then Google Drive.
And then here you can see all
of the apps that have some
integration with Google Drive.
So there's a lot.
We recommend you just take
a look through them.
There's a bunch of image
editors, presentation editors,
there's AutoCAD WS, if you
work with CAD documents.
CLAUDIO: And also to make it
easy to recognize Google Drive
applications, we added a
small logo, 2H listing.
So that is the Google
Drive logo on the
bottom right corner.
And if you click on one of those
listings, you will see
that it works with Google
Drive, which is
our badge for it.
VIC: Exactly.
Yep.
CLAUDIO: And, of course, as in
all applications in the Chrome
Web Store, you can read reviews
from other users.
You can see star rating,
and so on.
VIC: Yeah, so here's the
listing for Desmos.
You can see they have 142
five-star reviews.
So if we go into the reviews,
you can see this first review
here from a Google user,
"Nothing short of amazing.
Best thing out there.
It's so good.
I've never seen such a perfect
graphing calculator."
CLAUDIO: Yeah, it's an
amazing application.
VIC: Great application.
CLAUDIO: You should try it.
VIC: All right.
So that about wraps
it up for today's
Google Developers Live.
We have reviewed Desmos
Graphing Calculator.
CLAUDIO: See you next week.
Thank you very much.